What Jamie said,
this is what yours looks like,
but it has light.
Oh,
that's bad.
A similar,
she goes,
looks like Sorta,
sorta not like black.
And it's like,
whoa.
Mine is mine is the state of the art.
You have lights inside of yours?
No,
there's no lights.
No lights,
Bro.
Yeah,
I know what I'm doing.
I've been,
I had one of these in 2002 so I've had one forever.
Huh?
I loved them.
We should all love them.
Yeah.
I think one of the best tools ever for like thinking what else is a good
thinking tool?
Marijuana.
Yeah.
I heard you like marijuana.
Do you know,
like I,
you know what you have interesting thing for you.
What are you going to things?
Um,
so because I'm on a budget,
I left my job and everything.
I stayed at a hostel.
Dan,
I'm doing some broke people's Shit,
right?
You're saying hostile?
Probably not.
I've never stayed at a hostel.
So a in case you don't know what a hostile is,
which everyone listening to some of the is it's,
I shared a room with three other people with bunk beds.
Right,
right.
So,
you know,
Massachusetts just said,
hey listen,
you know,
we're gonna allow marijuana,
but it's still kind of like a taboo thing.
Right.
They don't want it getting too widespread.
So when I came here to the hostile,
uh,
I walked in and there's a giant bag of marijuana on the table and I was like,
I'm sorry if someone's selling this.
Is this like,
no,
it's for you man.
Like we welcome all the guests like this.
You could have as much as you want.
I was like,
where am I?
Or
Dude,
crazy,
crazy shit.
Now you reels smoke box the other day?
Yeah,
I think I'm just starting to be non,
not high really from that,
from the other day.
So is it out yet?
I don't know if he's released yet.
Anyway,
they gave me a bag of weed that every time I opened up the trunk of my Tesla,
it's like,
whoa.
So what?
So over a skunk.
I'm not very familiar with with smoking marijuana.
I think I've done it like once you work for the government,
I don't know.
I don't like once and it's like I try to be cool like,
yeah,
you smoke,
right?
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Who Does it right then?
So I was,
so they offered me this big bag of weed and I was like terrified.
I should be,
because the thing is like if I try it,
I want to be where I'm somewhere safe.
I'm not going do Croak.
It's only marijuana.
It's not like,
you know,
you don't want to freak out.
Right.
That could happen and you,
you should only take a little,
like if you're gonna,
if you're gonna say this is what you do,
you go like this,
like this,
like it's a little,
yeah,
just a touch.
You know,
there's the smoke box.
First of all,
be real smoke me in Tacoma,
I quit maybe five minutes into the smoke box and I was like,
what in the fuck am I doing?
We got high before we got into the smoke box to somebody.
So it's still the souls of stoners.
So smoke box and you quit or were you in a car?
It was like a dedicated system.
That's the car.
It's a,
an old Cadillac look.
A barbecued.
I am.
I can't even keep my eyes open.
Wait,
that's you a,
yeah.
I'm like,
I can't believe you still smoke cause even look like you.
Exactly.
I'm so high.
I'm on another dimension.
Holy Shit.
Let's look.
You're freaking great.
Grandfather looked at me.
Uh,
that's followed lighting.
But the uh,
that's crazy.
What be real does is he gets you in that car and then everybody has a fat tube,
like a big giant joint of the most ridiculous weed on the planet earth.
Those nuns stronger.
So why not?
So I don't understand.
What's the point of having a joint?
Just go in the car and get high that way.
Everybody's so hot.
You can't breathe.
There's no air in there.
When I got out of there,
my inside of my mouth was cooked.
Yeah.
If he's never smoked weed,
he doesn't understand the hotbox constant on it.
I don't understand this sound busy.
All that smoke you're breathing in,
right?
So you're,
you're smoking it so you're getting high from that and then you breathe in and
other people smoke.
You get an extra hot.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no air,
so why don't I just go in there and just be like,
Hey,
you know what?
I'm just going to sit in here for five minutes and get high than,
yeah,
you'd get high from that.
I probably wouldn't get really high from that.
Your professional?
Yeah.
He smoked every day?
No.
Okay.
Every other day?
No.
Sundays on,
no,
but I've been taking this stuff every day.
Is that the DMT?
This is CBD with THC.
It's 10 milligrams of THC and 10 milligrams of CBD.
So it's not a lot of THC,
but it's enough.
So you just put those pills in like your coffee or something?
I just swallow it.
It's like a little joke cap.
Well isn't that like not fun because it's not,
you're not smoking.
It looks like it's like a fish oil pill.
Yeah,
exactly.
But it's CBD oil with THC.
It's a hemp oil.
So you just,
you just pop it in and you're like,
oh swallow it.
No,
I take that back.
I did have a marijuana chocolate.
When was this?
Yeah,
this was like,
uh,
last year.
How'd it go?
Nothing.
It was,
it was like nothing.
I probably didn't take enough.
My friends like you didn't take enough so I had it and they're like an hour,
an hour later.
This is dumb.
I just sat there,
got a little high and I was just like,
Nah,
it wore off and went to sleep and it was fine.
I didn't take enough.
Yeah,
you definitely didn't take it though.
I was worried the other way.
Yes.
Way Too much.
Like this is dumb and to have like five more pieces of Trump's,
that's what people do.
The worst thing anybody could ever say when they eat pot is,
man,
I don't feel shit is dumb.
And then they take another one.
Yeah.
And then it kicks in and then it gets in your DNA and you're like,
oh no.
Then your kids are high and then you're a wild ride.
You're on a ride for like hours.
Really?
Oh my God.
I have a friend who ate too many edibles and he was high for 27 or 28 hours.
Wow.
A full day later,
he was still high and it took like four hours after that.
What is this guy's doing?
The leaf blower.
What does that do?
And it's making a giant hotbox out of this [inaudible] biggest fans go crazy.
It gets,
and why you would want to see some stoners like that girl right there at,
they just get too high.
Yeah,
like me.
So it was in the hot box.
Like what?
Can you not do?
Everything.
Can't do anything.
So good at talking.
So is it like getting drunk?
No,
no,
no.
You get paranoid and get freaked out.
I think about people you fingered in high school.
Oh,
you start,
you'll fucking,
you comb over everything you've ever done,
ever.
That might be even remotely questionable.